[Musik]
so nehme jetzt verteidigungsminister
heute der große ball der offiziere sie
waren ja auch noch mal beim bundesheer
aber bei jahre habe ich mir erzählen
lassen wenn der alte erinnerungen wach
auf alle fälle war ja 13 jahre aktiv
beim bundesheer aber natürlich ein paar
wir heute hier in der hofburg gehen das
am wunderschönen rahmen ist nicht
alltäglich ich kenne er auch den gefecht
diensten und nicht nur das feiern aber
heute bin ich froh dass wir da sein darf
und auch den ball eröffnen darf es erst
mal für sich der ball offiziere ist das
erste mal und ich bin schon sehr
gespannt und ich weiß der mann ist ein
wunderbarer und vorgänger freut mich
auch wieder sehr viele bekannte
gesichter wieder zu sehen was meine
aktiven dienst hat jetzt muss ich
natürlich die frage stellen die zeit
genießen darf man soll man muss man
feiern auf alle fälle trotzdem das ist
eine österreichische gute kultur ich als
steiner im feiern das können wir auch
ganz gut und ich glaube das bundesheer
hat auch etwas zu feiern nämlich glaube
ich einen sehr guten weg den wir
eingeschlagen haben in den letzten
jahren wieder etwas mehr geld auch eine
gute struktur und ich glaube ja es wird
auch schon der ballnacht werden und ich
glaube bin ich der erste der auf hätte
es glaube ich mit sicherheit alles als
kerner kann also sagen wir kennen die
wissen wie man feiert aber das motto
heute 100 jahre republik ist natürlich
auch an ein motto das man ruhig feiern
kann
auf alle fälle hat das ist richtig das
motto ist ein großes und ich glaube dass
das bundesheer auch sehr viele aufgaben
diesem jahr übernehmen wird nämlich
nicht nur repräsentative aufgaben
sondern auch natürlich wenn es um die
sicherheit und den schutz auch geht und
ich freue mich auch auf die sehr vielen
festveranstaltungen im zuge dieser das
große jubiläums letzte frage vielleicht
abseits vom und mal die minister rolle
haben sie jetzt schon ein paar monate
oder einige der sommer bis einige wochen
mich schon eingelebt nachfolger fälle
also ich sage die nebel lichten sich
schon langsam natürlich das kann man
immer wieder neue auch dazu aber ich
glaube ich habe einen vorteil ich
verstehe die sprache der militärs 70
prozent zumindest und die restlichen 30
eigentlich mehr heute wieder wünsche ich
eine so wie sie es gesagt am rauschenden
ballnacht herzlichen dank ebenfalls
danke
[Musik]
[Applaus]